imaginemos que tenemos una piscina con
agua una piscina con agua y aviento una
piedra que cae en el centro de dicha
piscina con agua y unos instantes
después una honda una pequeña honda se
mueve radialmente hacia afuera con
respecto a donde cayó la piedra deja de
ver que también puedo dibujar esto aquí
la tenemos
esta es la onda que se mueve radialmente
hacia afuera de donde cayó la piedra es
un círculo cuyo centro es donde la
piedra cayó en el agua supongamos que en
este momento el radio el radio es de
tres centímetros tres centímetros y
también supongamos que este radio está
creciendo a una razón de un centímetro
por segundo vamos a escribir esto
radio
creciendo creciendo a razón de un
centímetro por segundo entonces dado
esto que el radio es tres centímetros y
que este radio está creciendo a una
razón de un centímetro por segundo la
pregunta es a qué razón está el área del
círculo creciendo a qué razón
a qué razón esta área de círculo
creciendo a qué razón está el área del
círculo creciendo interesante pensemos
entonces en lo que sabemos y en lo que
no sabemos en lo que estamos intentando
calcular si llamamos a este radio r
sabemos entonces que el radio es igual a
3 centímetros y también sabemos que el
radio r está creciendo a razón de un
centímetro por segundo y esta
información la podemos poner como de
rehén de la razón a la que crece el
radio con respecto al tiempo es igual a
1 centímetro por segundo un centímetro
por segundo y que nos están preguntando
nos están preguntando a qué razón está
el área creciendo en este caso sería la
razón a la que crece a a es el área con
respecto al tiempo de jaén de t la razón
a la que crece el área con respecto al
tiempo es lo que nos están preguntando
lo que necesitamos aquí entonces es una
relación entre el área del círculo y el
radio del círculo para posteriormente
derivar esa expresión con respecto al
tiempo haciendo uso de la regla de la
cadena entonces cuál es la relación en
todo momento entre el radio del círculo
y el
área del círculo bien por geometría
básica sabemos que el área del círculo
es igual a pi por el radio del círculo
al cuadrado ahora queremos calcular la
derivada del área con respecto al tiempo
así es que derivamos ambos lados de esta
expresión con respecto al tiempo déjame
dar me acerque un poco más despacio o
hacer un poco más de espacio aquí voy a
reescribir lo que teníamos que spears x
radio al cuadrado y voy a tomar entonces
la derivada de ambos lados con respecto
al tiempo la derivada de a con respecto
al tiempo no está derivando con respecto
a r estoy derivando ambos lados con
respecto al tiempo entonces del lado
izquierdo que va a tener la derivada del
área la derivada del área déjame hacerlo
en verde la derivada del cáncer del x
ponerlo con el coro adecuado ahora si
del lado izquierdo tengo la derivada de
a con respecto a t la viva el área con
respecto al tiempo y del lado derecho
vamos a derivar piporé al cuadrado con
respecto al tiempo voy a sacar esta
constante es más fácil si saco
constantes entonces va a ser pi por la
elevada con respecto al tiempo del radio
al cuadrado y para dejar en claro lo que
voy a hacer porque voy a usar la regla
de la cadena estamos suponiendo que eres
una función que depende del tiempo
cierre no estuviera en función del
tiempo tampoco estaría en función del
tiempo aquí sólo escrito r déjame ser
explícito que depende del tiempo r de t
elevado al cuadrado y queremos encontrar
entonces la derivada de esto con
respecto al tiempo y aquí tenemos que
aplicar la regla de la cadena estamos
tomando la derivada de algo elevado al
cuadrado con respecto a ese algo la
derivada de algo elevado al cuadrado es
dos por s algo elevado a la 1
entonces voy a hacerlo aquí más claro
estamos tomando la derivada de r
cuadrada rd t elevado al cuadrado con
respecto a rd t si hubiera sido la
derivada de x cuadra con respecto a x
ésta sería 2x así es que la derivada de
ere de t al cuadrado con respecto a er
det es igual a 2 r de t
pero ésta no es aún la derivada con
respecto al tiempo esta es la derivada
tan solo con respecto a er det para
obtener la derivada de rd t al cuadrado
con respecto al tiempo necesitamos
multiplicar esto de aquí por la razón a
la que cambia r de t
con respecto al tiempo a la que cambia r
de t con respecto al tiempo entonces la
tasa a la que erre te cambia con
respecto al tiempo lo puedes escribir
simplemente como de r en dt estas dos
son equivalentes
y todo esto multiplicado por ti quiero
insistir que aquí tenemos la red de la
cadena aplicada estamos todo la derivada
de algo elevado con respecto al tiempo
tomamos primero la derivada de algo
elevado con respecto a ese algo y lo
multiplicamos por la derivada de ese
algo con respecto al tiempo nunca está
de más insistir
que aquí estamos aplicando la regla de
la cadena regla de la cadena tenemos
entonces que pi por esto es igual a la
derivada del área con respecto al tiempo
bien deja de escribir esto aquí arriba
para que esté un poco más limpio que
tenemos que la derivada del área con
respecto al tiempo va a ser igual
ap x de hecho este 2 deja de ponerlo
antes 2 pi que multiplica a rd te voy a
poner ahora r simplemente ya sabemos que
depende del tiempo va a poner
simplemente r por déjame hacerlo en azul
para poner r en azul como lo estado
haciendo por la derivada del radio con
respecto al tiempo de r en dt bien
sustituyendo los valores que conocemos
que tenemos tenemos que r es igual a
tres centímetros en este momento r es
igual a tres centímetros
de eren dt también en este momento es un
centímetro por segundo un centímetro por
segundo y entonces dejan dt de a ende te
va a ser igual a 2 pi por 3 2 por 3 por
déjame usar el mismo color que tenía por
1 y simplemente para checar que tenemos
las unidades adecuadas veamos aquí
tenemos centímetro por centímetro a
centímetro cuadrado eso está muy oscuro
centímetro al cuadrado sobre segundo que
son unidades adecuadas para el cambio de
área tenemos entonces de jaén de la
razón a la que cambia el área con
respecto al tiempo es igual a dos por
tres
esto es seis pi ligeramente mayor a 18
centímetros cuadrados por segundo
centímetros cuadrados por segundo estoy
bien
dos por tres y 66 centímetros cuadros
por segundo que la razón a la que cambia
el área con
y hemos terminado